[Music]
[Applause]
all right
welcome back to the break room everybody
we're so happy to be here we're happy
you're joining us this is our daily show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know
and on today's show we'll be talking and
or
dr doom and wha oh oh there's breaking
news she's coming in what warner
brothers has canceled the break room
what we've been getting at
hang on a second i gotta get this
hello yeah you're kidding me
wait i just got cast in batgirl
this is my agent i've got some bad news
your agent's alive
shad shabbat chad chamez my agent uh
with me today uh we'll be talking about
all the crazy news coming out about uh
dc films uh uh but with me to discuss
all of that we've got brandon barrack
hello jessica clemons hello tommy bechto
gucci damuchi baby
and i'm zach huddleston we're all uh
really happy to be here with you today
uh as always we're doing a chat
redemption we appreciate everybody that
throws us a couple bucks in super chat
uh for every hundred dollars that we get
in super chats today we're going to be
doing singing impressions
now that should be self-explanatory well
i have questions already okay yeah what
are your questions are we singing an
impression as someone or are we doing an
impression of a singer like am i singing
an impression of
dick cavett oh
yeah yeah go to um uh no we will be we
will be singing we will be finishing our
points whatever we're talking about him
he's 86 years old and you
you'll have to donate a couple bucks to
see what that looks like tommy's singing
is enya go yes chrissy we could do that
i just might i just might i just might
oh don't give it away
and as always if you haven't already hey
follow the break room on tick tock yeah
we're on tick tock uh tommy producer
john other folks are posting really fun
we're going to be releasing a couple
bangers today and then tomorrow i've got
one that's really going to make a splash
ooh a splash a gush if you will
and that's again at the underscore break
room on tick tock uh thank you uh okay
we've got to lead with we kind of teased
it already so crazy report coming out
from warner brothers in dc
the batgirl film which has already been
shot it's already been done
but it when they were doing yeah
screenings of it yeah they did a
screening of it yeah because at one
point this was going to be theatrical
theatrically released got downgraded to
an hbo max film but they're still
working on it whatever
not only is it not going to release on
hbo max it's not going to release at all
that film has been shelved
cancelled dunzo yes and brandon fraser
gained all that weight for that other
[ __ ] to make that movie called the
whale about a fat guy when you could
just cast a fat person by the way and
also naming a fat person the whale is
problematic we can go on that'll be on
the back corner there's a movie i forget
what his name is he's one of those hot
directors everybody oh is this like
making a movie robert downey jr and uh
no bretta fraser is way 600 pounds in
this movie because he put on a ton of
weight and then he and then he wears a
fat too
darren aronofsky that's right yes well
god knows it's time for him to get back
on there with another movie with a great
theme okay
okay no this is a valid rant tommy we
got to stay on
do you think this has anything to do
with uh warner brothers merging with
discovery or do you think this has
something to do with hbo being like we
don't want this anymore we were we've
been discussing this ever since the news
broke a little under an hour ago this is
crazy first off just to give you a sense
now maybe you hadn't been following
there hasn't been like a trailer or a
lot of news about batgirl michael keaton
was playing an older batman brendan
frazier uh leslie grace from in the
heights was playing that girl they spent
90 million dollars jk simmons
like a little cw show or something like
that i mean a crazy way crazy way of
going about it but i think what if they
are doing it like they said in the chat
disney vaulting it they're just like
gonna put it away for a minute start a
lot of commotion about it i also think
like
like i don't know i don't think their
social press has been like great so this
would be like we're all talking about
this this is insane you guys shot it but
there has been also on accounts when
they did the justice league like showing
people were like don't
don't do this don't do that they're like
no we're gonna still do it so maybe it
could be like that do you think i mean
it's it's wild to think warner brothers
would do this it's probably just a
cost-saving thing right yeah they
already spent 90 million on this movie
they would probably have to spend an
equal amount promoting it right and
maybe maybe all the special effects
weren't done they're also talking this
is a little like hollywood insider
knowledge but like uh actors directors
producers they get paid when a movie is
like wrapped they get paid more when the
movie is released oh so they're just
keeping them maybe yeah maybe you know
michael keaton whoever like they can
shortchange him a little bit by not
releasing it i think this is a
post-merger thing yeah the new
leadership one of the guy uh people in
charge they were over at cnn when like
uh they released cnn plus and they
cancelled it immediately yeah i didn't
even know i saw the numbers weren't
going to be there yeah they're just
running long-term numbers it's worth it
for them to just like yeah
and again the yeah the executives who
greenlit this film are no longer there
and in charge it's wonderful and maybe
these new people are like this isn't my
project
after oh sorry no you go first your hand
rose you're okay i'm dressed like a
teacher for a reason it's not it's not a
this is not a democracy can i just offer
what i think might be this is a little
inside baseball please and again if you
you know if you don't work in the
industry
god saw you guys touching yourselves and
now you don't get back
guys come on okay mine was not that but
that is true sorry guys that you're not
wrong maybe keep your hands to
yourselves or not yourself keep your
hands in the air and wave them like you
just don't care
oh my god i hope not uh do you remember
how zack snyder when the whole situation
came out on the rolling stones was also
saying that like it took forever to get
the names of producers out of the
credits yes so maybe it could be so much
behind that like going off of like
people getting paid after it there's a
lot of people that change but people
still think they own credit to it there
could be so many behind the scenes of
like we can't figure it out so we're
just gonna we're gonna withhold it we're
going with all day until the time and
again this is wild now projects get
delayed cancelled all the time right we
can all if you've been following
films and tv shows for any amount of
time like even marvel movies get
cancelled or delayed or they get
mentioned and they never come to
fruition it's not a big deal but like
when it's already been shot and at least
edited enough that they can host
screenings like it's in a somewhat
finished place there's also some of the
other talent behind this um the two
directors who did a couple episodes of
miss marvel they also directed the most
recent bad boys bad boys for life they
had directed this film um it's this is a
wild story and again the the entire dc
eu which we have some more headlines
about coming up it's been a little bit
of chaos the last couple years the whole
snyder vs thing and a lot of what's
going on i mean everything that's going
on with the flash film um
this is just more evidence of uh that is
in a weird spot there is there's the
conspiracy side of me that says well
maybe they're doing this to build buzz
and they want to create an online
campaign release the bad girls
release it uh
and then they'll be like okay you guys
asked for it here we go uh i don't know
that's a very cynical
it just decided to take and if that is
what they're doing that's rude yes to
everyone involved people work hard no
one wants to make a bad movie no and it
you know everyone does their best and
like really tries and it's kind of sad
to go this far and everybody showed up
thinking this was going to be fun and
good right also before we move on the
other movie they got canceled at the
same time uh poor went out for scoob
holiday haunt
the scooby-doo film that was uh oh it
was the second to the movie the
2020 animated did we know what it was
going to be was it going to be like
arbor day they couldn't go through they
couldn't really get ransom
do you
do
remember
remember when you would click on that
movie and it was showing justice league
snyder [ __ ]
that's right
uh the wrong link um speaking of uh
dc things coming to an end it was
announced that this the cw flash series
will be ending after nine seasons
nine seasons is a pretty good run for
any show that's a great run for the show
nine seasons you know what else ran for
nine seasons the middle on abc available
on hbo max unlike
you still get residuals tommy maybe i
will if you tune in
um other dc news james gunn clarified
that peacemaker season two
is going to be in the dc eu peacemaker
has always been in the dceu will
continue to be in the dc but will there
be a dc eu for him to be in yeah that's
a great question i mean we know we're
getting shazam black adam aquaman 2 and
a flash film they're still i think uh
peacemaker is to the dc eu as deadpool
is to the mcu where it's like this is so
crazy the the uh peacemaker was insane
there's a there's absolutely where you
get a straight shot of a vagina on a
like ipad so like it's so insane that
they're probably like oh we can wait
you can wait yeah this is funny when the
first like feature-length peacemaker
movie is the next justice league yes
yeah but he he's the the colonel of the
dcu that grows one thing that survives
yeah i would like to see him interacting
with the shazam cast that sounds fun oh
my gosh like a very fun opportunity
yeah kind of a tonal fit kind of in a
weird way i think that's better um and
in james gunn mcu news
he uh
tweeted or that uh he considers the
holiday special the upcoming holiday
special that we still don't have a date
or a trailer for uh to be essential
viewing before watching guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. he says there's a lot of
big information in there okay well then
give us something let's try james
again video for you we're assuming you
know marvel has been playing it tight
with these trailers close to the
releases we just got in july we got a
black panther trailer for a november
release so maybe for a december uh
holiday special release maybe in august
if the d23 is around the corner that's
right that is true also we're starting a
campaign especially if this is like a
disney plus only thing yes yeah uh
everybody um
we want to go to we want to try to do
this show live yeah at
d23 so let them know um yeah please if
you have um if if your your
dad is the president of disney yeah just
just give him a pokemon
if you're susie jpeg that's daddy let
him know
the break room will come there we'll
kiss everybody we'll we'll we'll do the
show
spirit jessica live she's not going to
be there she's definitely going to be
there i'm going to be in costa rica
that would be in costa rica
slash d23
in some way because guess what she's
always in my heart the costa rica
neighborhood of anaheim she will be
there little costa rica
um
so we're eagerly anticipating both d23
and any guardians of the galaxy holiday
special news um we got a clip from an
interview from comic-con that just came
out uh black panther 2 actress leticia
wright uh revealed an interview how
shuri her character reacts to t'challa's
death in wakanda forever she was asked
about that and i think do we have the
clip john
yeah shuri definitely is
consumed with her work the loss of her
brother causes her to be so consumed
with her work that she's creating at
another level at a higher level actually
so there's so much new technology to
look forward to um and i think i think
that's where her sweet spot is at the
moment like how do i process this and
she just throws all of her energy even
more so into technology so there's a lot
of cool new things to look out for yeah
yes you know what i i like that great
answer first off because like though um
grief is an interesting emotion to
explore and we think it'll be explored
somewhat in wakanda forever but like
it's a relatively inactive emotion to
portray on screen right people just
being sad so it's like how nice to make
it like active and cinematic by like she
channels her grief into her work and
thus we get cool gadgets and crazy
costumes and stuff like that right i'm
dying on that hill which i it honestly
might have honestly been uh
set in stone but i do think that she's
gonna be creating the new faux herb that
they don't have anymore so i think like
just putting all her energy in that with
riri is what we're gonna really see this
would be for all my morbius fans out
there this would be like the blue blood
of the earth
but also if it's synthesized it's part
of the problem with the blue blood if
it's synthesized does that mean we could
get hundreds thousands of people super
soldier serum it's out there well and as
soon as you create like a mcguffin
special thing you have to also find a
way for it to be an incredibly limited
supply right yeah like you've killed 10
vials in the world
for no reason well the thing is she's
gonna have to test it on something oh
maybe it's ours on ourselves yeah
all right so we got we have had a few uh
super chats come in we appreciate that
we're not quite yet close to anyone
singing and which would be a real shame
because we've got
at least two of us can carry a tune on
this channel so
you know let's definitely lesson less
than four yeah more than one i would say
yeah like one point three um and yeah uh
shout out to mike chiro cairo i
apologize don't know how your name's
pronounced mike but um can you guys make
an epic hero tomicon t-shirt with all
your silhouettes and cosplay please
that's a great idea we would love that
we want merch we're looking for merch if
you want merch same as the d23 you gotta
tweet at new rockstars let them know
what you want from us break room there's
no limit to what we can do we want to do
this show in space yeah okay
so uh gucci dammucci headbands huh maybe
look at that right there your name here
maybe like one of those internet porn
stars i start writing your names on my
headband for a few bucks what do i care
you want me to carve your name in my arm
with a pen i'll do it yeah don't worry
don't do that
oh and we've had a couple polls in the
chat that we should uh shout out do you
think we will ever see this batgirl
movie
no it's doomed six years old
sixty percent think never we'll see it
it's coming out oh we'll see like a day
of the clown and the other famed uh lost
to history films uh
uh okay wow but that's still 40 think
eventually we'll see it it's gonna it's
gonna like they're gonna drop it on hbo
max at midnight on like a sunday in two
years and then yeah they'll be like oh
that's out now yes um do you still watch
any air reverse shows 77 saying no and
we also don't know are those people
saying they never watched an era of our
show or they did and they've stopped i
don't know i i have found my journey
with the arrowverse and i'm sure a lot
of people out there are similar i have
never watched it
in the moment that it comes out i have
exclusive
shows binged on netflix it's just easier
that way like it's easier to get through
because they all kind of
they there are some that i will say are
not necessarily essential viewing you
can skip a couple that are just kind of
monster of the week episodes and still
stay on the main plot because they i
mean they make like 23 episodes with
those seasons oh and there's often
multiple shows going at the same time
which is how tv used to be uh circling
back here to headline
in the good old days when dick cavett
ruled the airwaves and we've already uh
uh tried to characterize the break room
as the dick cavett of nerdy noises
make one timely reference i'd rather be
with dick cavett than i have a cabinet
for a dick that much
dear lord
oh put that joke on ice okay um
speaking of d23 we got some
announcements we kind of been assuming
this but we got it confirmed that marvel
and lucasfilm are gonna have big
presences at g23 the kind of disney
uh focused comic-con that is coming up
september 10th right around the corner
um that uh yeah filmmakers celebrity
talent surprise guest from marvel will
join lucasfilm and others on stage in
hall uh d23 to showcase theatrical and
disney plus titles so we internally have
been speculating we think there's going
to be some pixar announcements almost
certainly some pixar announcements maybe
the next star wars film gets announced
here we know a lot of star wars series
but we don't know what the next movie is
but we know they're making that move
tiger white tt's making a movie right
uh and then there's another series
that's the only movie we really know
about we've got skeleton crew series
acolyte sierra
ahsoka mando mando season there's also
this like rogue squadron movie that we
think is cancelled they haven't really
ever said but like
maybe in the same way that kevin feige
really put to bed a lot of speculation
by laying out the next four years of
marvel films maybe lucasfilm will do
kind of a similar thing um and again
there's a lot of gaps in that marvel
release calendar so maybe they were
saving some stuff for d23 right
particularly series right so maybe some
casting news and directing news so again
we're going to be we're trying to be
there disney if you're listening we want
to be broadcasting is still alive
we're going to break some more news
today
dick kevin found alive
who said he was dead
yeah we never said he was dead we just
said references to dick cabbage should
be dead
come on the show dick dick
face me in the octagon or debate me on
the break room but one way or another
i'm on a collision course with dick oh
yes but uh back to uh
disney we wanna we wanna broadcast live
from d23 if if nothing else some of us
will be going uh some representatives
from uh new rockstars will be there
we're gonna maybe try to be uh
broadcasting live the day of d23 we're
very excited about it yeah um now we're
gonna transition
talk speaking of disney release schedule
all of our ears perked up when the
fantastic four film got released and
like what villain immediately came to
mind
doctor small man
well you're a mole man stan you know i
love my roger corman fantastic four they
had moment and couldn't call him that so
they just called him like the the guy
the underdweller the upper taker
shout out tim jennings adventure of the
undertaker
oh no and so ever since i got announced
we're like ooh are we going to get a
doctor doom is he going to be the
villain that film what else could dr
doom show up in obviously he has a lot
of connections to black panther
in in the comics and uh presumably maybe
in future films uh and so we've been
speculating internally about how dr doom
could show up in future mcu films and
jessica you've done a bunch of research
you have a lot of thoughts on this
so uh our biggest question here is how
is doom gonna enter the mcu before
secret wars because we're assuming he's
absolutely gotta be in secret wars
because we have the 1984 secret wars
where he is still the
the he basically he's not like the king
of it but he is the one that's like i'm
the leader all the evil people are
stupid work through me and then we got
the 2015 about uh the 2015 issues where
they enter battle world and he's
basically getting a lot of his power
through a molecule man through the
beyonders the beyonders in the 1984 run
were the ones that were basically like
fight i want to see you guys do it and
then yeah and then ultron freaked out
and spazzed out and got killed by
galactus and galactus was like i'm not
doing this shot up to the sky and got
blasted down and galactus being like the
strongest
thing
is insane that shows how like un like
non-powerful everyone is there so doom
has to be entering it before secret wars
and plus he does have some ties in
secret wars to kang the conqueror king
the conqueror shoots him down from the
sky uh and then he goes back and kills
kang with ultron's body ultron could be
white vision
how
would that be known how is it possible
to even what what movies do you guys
think we could see him in from phase 5
possibly
um we also have a graphic of phase five
i'm so sorry that uh john can bring it
up for anyone that's used to some of the
potential properties right like well
obviously
they're in the comics there's a doctor
doom connection to black panther so
there's some speculation does he show up
in wakanda forever right because like
they're you know namor
kind of being pitched as the antagonist
of this film the bad guy but we know
he's kind of a an anti-hero or whatever
they're probably at some point he'll be
fighting with the wakandans instead of
just against the wakandans so is there
another baddie that they have to join
forces to defeat there's that kind of
speculation obviously then fantastic
four would make a lot of sense are there
other places where it makes sense for
doctor doom to arrive
i can i see the graphic one more time um
i i can't see behind dash i'm so sorry
we got guardians we got quantum mania
the thing is i feel like a good spot if
we wanted to hit really quick is either
quantum mania or loki yes um one of
those two i don't
really want to so i think it was me and
mt we were talking briefly about him
showing up
and uh can you bring up the graphic one
more time
showing up in guardians of the galaxy
but i don't think we're gonna see him in
guardians of the galaxy i think put him
up against something that's really big
and not saying that the guardians aren't
big i'm just saying
compared to
all of wakanda
they're of no match now brandon you were
even speculating before we were rolling
do we see victor von doom before we see
doctor
yeah because the the thing with dr drew
that's like crazy is labaria right yeah
another
fictional location that they haven't
addressed yet in the mcu
so i i've always thought they haven't
even teased it on like a map in the
background or anything like that yeah
i've always thought it would make sense
if they're not from this universe and
like dr doom and all the librarians
they're from another earth and like uh
one that's like being destroyed from an
incursion and he brings them all over he
brings over like a whole country yeah uh
and they come over and then and
everyone's like oh they're refugees we
gotta help them and then slowly turns
into dr duke yeah or is doctor dude the
whole time
pretending to be victor vaughn yeah
pretending to be nice but to answer your
question where they might show up it
could be in ant-man and the wasp quantum
medium yeah because that was described
as like a team up yes it's the first uh
new face
and i think that's like a weird place
where doom could come in as like a hero
and help like defeat a kang or something
like that and they're like oh doom's
great bring him in his last name's doom
what could go wrong
and then he flips the switch at some
point instead of him working with reid
it would be nice to see him working
under hank pym would that make sense oh
interesting something in there i feel he
the only thing that doesn't stick with
me with that is that he is like the
smartest man uh victor von doom so it's
like why would he be working under hank
wouldn't he be way above hanging maybe
he could be younger he could still be on
the come out i mean the smartest
rankings in the mcu you know the power
rankings of brains it's it's all over
the place because like so many of our
heroes are supposed to be like super
geniuses yeah who's the most super hyper
intelligent i don't know i'll even throw
out the mcu has shown a willingness to
fudge to shift uh traditional comics
backgrounds right like neymar not from
atlantis as far as we know in the mcu
what if doctor doom is from sokovia
in the mcu have they gone to that well
too many times
yeah i don't know if if baron
nemo knows that the sokovian well is
almost dry but there is one last drop
and his name is victor vanduul
i just want if he does show up in black
panther
i don't
do we want him to immediately be a
villain is he just showing up last
minute
just teased kind of like thanos was the
first couple times we saw him right like
maybe he's just in a post-credits scene
in a few of these films i mean black
panther could be a great time where if
you know it's like wakanda was revealed
and they've opened themselves up to the
world and now
talocan uh the the atlantis right is
gonna be revealed if this is like the
breaking point and it's like okay all
the secret nations time to show
yourselves and we get like 50 all at
once
they're all here now i think we're gonna
see sorry i'm also going at the chat and
you brandon i think we will see liveria
eventually but you can't have it
you can't have it unless you see already
battle world right you can't you can't
have one without the other so you
wouldn't see it until after probably
secret wars um they in the i think it's
in
the 84-2 the beyonder in the 84 run the
beyonders straight up like wiped the
galaxy and then all the pieces of earth
came back together but in nine in the
2015 run it was made of different parts
of the multiverse so that's why there's
so many different people from different
places that's why we have peter parker
and miles morales that's why we have a
thor army called the thor corps so it's
just like
uh getting all getting all those people
to come back
is what makes battle ward which makes a
lot variable and and arrogant
thor core
hardcore
okay okay uh we've we've got a strong
one i know
first the sea turtles and now jessica
haven't you done enough plastic straws
haven't you done it we've all had to
straw up our nose now and then come on
all right
um whoa all the way to the brain um
well we've also been talking a lot about
like kevin feige is saying that wakanda
forever is the end of phase four and
quantum mania is the beginning of phase
five and it seems like there must be
some reason behind that designation both
those films were announced at the same
time they've both been in development
for a similar amount of time they're
releasing just a couple months apart why
why draw the line there instead of after
quantum mania after some other project
you got to save on taxes you know you're
only allowed six marvel movies a tax
season i i think i think i've got it
okay i think i've got it at the end of
uh uh black panther wakanda forever
uh neymar is in a cell he's been he's
been detained even if they do fight
together and give him any water is it a
wet cell it's a wetsuit like when you
buy a turtle at the fair and it's got a
little does he need to be in water or is
that just something like beer water
he'll be submerged he's on land fighting
he's fine he's like i'm gonna sell and
all of a sudden the guard goes hey
you got a visitor
he goes in and then the shadowy figure
comes through the door and goes
hi i am a diplomat from la verria oh
you can call me victor but my friends
call me
doctor doom oh
i would like that to be which we have
have we seen in mcu yet someone that's
like
um my whole goal is creating this well i
guess it's thanos uh because i was about
to say i like the idea of him going and
being like i'm creating a different
world my whole intention is to create a
different culture vulture's going to
show up at the present yeah with dr
michael morbius and be like we could do
some cool things yeah we got it i like
that if like that's a pitch it's almost
like a reverse nick fury right rather
than like hey i'm putting together a
team to save the world hey i'm putting
together a new world i'm putting
together a new world new world order i
mean especially maybe talocan gets
destroyed in the course of black panther
my favorite part about secret wars is or
about all the battle world is what comes
after it the different factions of
different people in different areas and
what they stand for and a force is one
of my favorite things and so it's just
like i want to see that different
country that's these superheroes mainly
in a force it was like all women uh that
were part of arcadia a she-hulk's part
but uh i want to see the different
factions and then i want to see all the
marvel zombies on the outside of the
world so it's like i i want to see it
maybe we already have fave uh phase five
and six already readied up because
they're like we're going with doctor
doom after this after kang we're going
doctor doom and there's so much storage
well and and i'll just throw this out
there i was speculating before we
started rolling
what if marvel has a history of
using working titles right again working
title is an industry term where they
call a movie something but that's not
what it's eventually going to be called
right maybe they even do this on purpose
to throw us off the scent because what
if avengers kang dynasty is really going
to be
avengers doomsday or avengers or
whatever right avengers kang meets his
doom yes maybe they're teasing that kang
is going to be the next big you know
multi-chapter
uh villain and maybe he will
but what if it's not and actually kang
is just going to be in quantum mania
maybe a few other properties but then
doom is actually going to be the main
bad guy in those two avengers movies can
you imagine keanu reeves fighting
jonathan majors that's who i think is
gonna be playing dude i think they're
doing fan services so much that they're
like okay they keep asking for keanu
reeves i'm just gonna give them keanu
reeves speaking of fan service it
happened finally i trimmed my hedges
last night we want to thank manscape for
sponsoring the break room this week hey
you yeah you how are your hedges doing
are you looking like a family that just
moved in and are taking good care of
their lawn are you an old abandoned lot
full of horrors and strange overgrown
hedges and weird things coming out take
control your hedge it's important
these products are so good you're going
to be showing pride in your new hedge
free yard or trim down group like edward
scissorhands but you're not using that
you're using man's skin just to be clear
tommy um the metaphor you're using
hedges in this case are pubic hair
that's right and you're showing these
consensually right you're not forcing
people to view your hedges i mean that's
implied and you could shave a normal
hedge with it right you could all yeah i
mean it's got a ceramic blade i mean
it's a fact
you will have the best kept nut sack on
your block
stay big and be the most hygienic
version of yourself guys it matters okay
girls sometimes are very polite to you
and they're like no it's fine it's not
fine
girls or guys i will say we have a uh a
lawnmower 4.0 here this is the actual
product you get when you order the
performance package that's right which
is like kind of a starter set that
manscape sells it also comes with this
the weed whacker which is a nose and ear
if you happen to have your hair trimmer
that the weed whacker is great i've used
this many times as my one of the few
places on my body i can grow hair is out
of my nose prove it
and uh both the weed whacker and the the
lawnmower are great because they're kind
of foolproof areas like the inside of
your nose or where pubic hair lives you
don't want to be messing around that's
right you don't want to be
you're going to make like you're moved
i will say
the the um again
basically a hairless arm already but
look at this no snags it's meant to be
super they have skin safe technology
you're gonna you can't hurt yourself
have you ever used this yet i just want
to take a look no that's that's a fresh
one both of these none of these have
been used on any anyway i'll be using
that to shave my chest later in the week
yes and i'll be using this too and again
you can if you want to try out these
kind of products which you should they
also come the performance package comes
you get a pair of underwear you get some
like a cologne and like a crop reviver
thank god dick cavett reviving this crop
we're here we thought his crop was
barren come on the show show your crap
um and you get all these you can get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
when you use the promo code breakroom
and it's super important please use that
because that um not only saves you money
it makes us look very good to our
friends at manscape and helps us keep
this show on the eyes when you do it
i'll do it
i'll do it i'll make myself more
attractive it's super safe it's super
safe it's got skin safe technology look
at this um this is great it is it also
it looks nice if somebody saw that in
your bathroom sink they wouldn't think
you were doing anything gross with it no
yeah someone breaks into your house just
raiding your bathroom for pills and they
see this yeah think about this
can you see that there's an led light oh
see this is showing up on the screen
because
often where people care lives yeah it's
dark
and let's be honest not all of us can
afford to pay our electric bills let me
tell you how many times that led light
has saved me from what i call a sac
incursion
okay
john krasinski teaches us about that and
uh
my name is dr reed richards uh do you
have children i would like you someday
then use the manscape 4.0 in this led
light otherwise you're going to end up
barren you're going to look like scarlet
witch wandering the earth looking for
made-up children because you wrapped
your sack
with a non-ceramic led blade don't uh
don't rack your sack not on our account
quit racking your sack stop being wack
says zach uh and that's again 20 off and
free shipping at manscape.com when you
use our code break room break room all
one word uh it's time you level up from
the amazon to the amadong that's right
with the ultimate bushwhacking tools
from manscape now we've got a little bit
of breaking news also
uh nicole kang very uh fine actress from
you and batwoman played poison ivy on
cw's batwoman recently she tweeted at
marvel studios yesterday that said she
shared a name with the titular character
in the upcoming avengers kang dynasty it
might be destiny that she work on it
called as i said play poison ivan
batwoman she's excellent let's be honest
this definitely falls into a thirsty
thespian category that's that's a term
we've coined here on the break room i
believe we might have even come up with
it live on air i think so uh for any
time an actor
either in an interview or maybe tweeting
is openly kind of like asking to
reappear or to be cast in a big
franchise right yeah and there's no
shame involved in that term we
are thirsty as hell we beg you for super
chats of which we're sitting on a lowly
66 dollars right now with you guys um we
are thirsty we would all gladly uh
grovel at the feet of kevin feige or any
other studio executive to show up
creators of barney
if you're looking to put some guy in
that big purple suit
i'm halfway with my high blood pressure
i can already turn myself a shade of
purple that doctors describe as oh
so
just get me in there i don't have to be
a dinosaur just call me barney the
purple neighbor i love you
so uh god is thinking uh this um actress
this king actress uh asking to be in ken
dynasty got us thinking about like other
thirsty thespian moments yes we wanted
to go into like
what defines a thirsty pheasant yes well
we have that here i've we've created a
scale we took it to the labs the new
rockstars break room labs uh and we've
created a three-tiered scale now for our
first thespians first scale this is the
highest the sahara now this is when an
actor fan casts themselves and openly
campaigns for the role in media on
twitter you know anywhere this is like
for those of you old heads you know i i
googled this because this happened way
before i was born sean young put on a
full cat woman suit and ambushed tim
burton i believe at the emmy awards or
the golden globes that was on the warner
brothers live
but she also did it at an award show
because there's video footage of it
google sean young catwoman i promise you
even if you're a cool young gen zer you
will enjoy how cringy this clip is okay
it is insane she wanted to be catwoman
she bought the think about this she
bought the costume it's not a bad
looking costume then she went to the
director of the movie and did the
character for him yes and this was she
was a working famous actress at the time
she's been a lot of [ __ ] blade runner
yes she's the main female uh and blade
runner whatever uh yeah famously did not
work out for her did not but on the flip
side somebody not quite that cringy but
simulu yes our buddy
we're looking for you come on the show
come on the show see me talk to us we
want to talk barbie yeah
come on come talk barbie we want to also
talk chunky of course now
grade two
ladwp la department of water and power
limiting water usage so you're a little
thirsty you're medium thirsty this is
when an actor just retweets
complimentary fan casting or like people
being like you know who would be a great
fantastic four john krasinski
and he's like ah maybe
and finally our last category is
i'm a bit thirsty
and that is when the actor acknowledges
that this role exists and would be fun
to play but this isn't really like
lobbying for yeah so
we now know what a thirsty thespian is
we now know
the ranking so what everyone's gonna do
for
surprise it's mandatory whoa
that's right you thought i forgot
we had done this graphic
mine is the one that's away from those
so anyway other one
all right that's right it's mandatory
fun the segment that has swept the
nation and caused me to ration ration my
uh amount of times i play the graphic
because we just can't afford it hit it
again
like cost us 50 bucks every time they're
gonna shout just just in warner brothers
to shelf the break room what
we did that
we're going to be streaming on crank tv
uh now
okay here's how it's going to go i've
asked each of you to do a pic
a thespian who's been a little thirsty
lately uh and defend them and then the
other three of us are going to decide
how thirsty that take was and that
defense was and that the character is
and that's how much you've got to drink
okay you got to drink if your character
is a sahara you drink the whole glass if
your character has an ladwp water usage
limitation you drink half the glass if
your character is just
i guess i am a little bit thirsty you
just take a little sip now do we do this
in classic ventriloquist fashion where
we have to be drinking while we do
[Applause]
[Music]
my feeling is yes we're over the hundred
dollars oh thank you jay brad in the
ghetto coming from canada our friends up
north speaking of simulu fellow canadian
jay brad thank you
um uh yeah what what is uh jay brad says
doom figures out a way to stop kang in
king dynasty so ends up being the hero
but the power goes to his head and he
decides only he can be trusted to rule
the remaining worlds and create battle
worlds
i like it that's a pretty good he'll be
king he will defeat a cannon
i i will go first i'm going to get us
started i'm going to defend
my girl nicole kang who we brought up
earlier okay first of all she's got the
pedigree she's already played a super
villain she played poison ivy and you
know and evolved from it was an
alternate origin story it wasn't uh it
wasn't pamela eyes or ivy or whatever it
was a character i believe named maria
maria
uh
it's the song part of the defense yeah
yeah i put a little gold in there uh so
anyway who was that was that your
celebrity singing no i wasn't sorry no
the poll already finished
oh no oh oh randy got one more one vote
100 one month wow
uh surely should we honor them
also let's look at nicole's other past
projects she was on the show you
on netflix series you know who's in bed
with netflix right now the russo
brothers you know who i think might be
ending up directing secret wars the
russo brothers okay okay so maybe she
gets
maybe they they force
everyone to put it in gang dynasty
let me get back here you know what her
first acting credit was the abc young
talent spotlight
uh showcase okay that was her first
acting credit on imdb who owns abc guys
disney who owns marvel guys disney
that's right nicole
get in your car and drive to anaheim
you're gonna be a star baby also come on
the show nicole come on the show [ __ ]
why not they filmed these down in there
yeah yeah
they filmed these in-house
they filmed all marvel movies at the
park
[Applause]
they got the characters yeah they
already got the extras all right so
that's it uh
i guess you guys now decide how thirsty
so you're you're you're defending her by
saying
you might say because she's acting in at
least three things yes well one of them
including one doesn't seem like it was
televised yeah maybe a show it was on
imdb and one of those things she played
a villain that we all know and she
didn't enjoy also i love that like i
mean her logic and i think she was just
making a joke on twitter we're not
blasting her in anyway but like her
logic that because her last name that
happens to be the name of a villain that
is showing up at the titular villain of
a film
like as if like um uh you know ryan
reynolds should show up in avengers
reynolds dynasty or something like that
right like reynolds wrapped now ryan
reynolds is a bit of a thirsty thespian
yes he did make his own little fan film
with without help from that effects show
it worked out good for him yeah that
didn't exist yeah all right so what am i
sahara what am i
that feels ladwp doesn't it to me it
feels very sahara oh okay
you're the deciding vote
i think she's also sahara okay finish
that class finish that glasses
finish that class oh my god
we didn't clarify either this is ever
clear
all right
the healthiest thing tommy's ever
checked that's right thank god
wait do we have a graphic for this oh
yeah we do have a pool guard
yeah
and i was like is that the guy from
goonies and then i realized that was an
actor in prosthetics anyway uh brandon
you won the super chat poll so why don't
you defend your thirsty thespian in a
song oh
okay uh love you they love you yeah well
you are you are you and jessica are the
best singers yeah are you doing it in
the style of a particular singer i can
i'll do a job petty tom petty that might
venture into bob dylan great
we're getting a traveling will berries
yeah
why russell he wanted to be
in a movie
man
well we'll do bob dylan that's more
toxic yeah you're changing though uh uh
he
he got interviewed this week man and he
wanted to be in thunderbolt c yeah but
they didn't want to put him in the movie
but he's already been cast
here comes the story of the u.s patriot
yeah he's in the fix man
uh he was uh asked in the digital fix if
he's gonna be in the thunderbolts movie
he was like i hope so man
they haven't called me oh no
oh god why are you wyatt come on the
show for a hug yeah he was kind of
complaining but yeah yeah this movie's
been announced in theory i'm gonna be a
core character but i have not been
contacted yet it's being directed by
jake schreier who he's worked with on a
show called lodge49 great on that show
2018. look it up if you haven't seen it
yet uh and so he's like i kind of want
to just call jake and be like what's
going on man uh because he he kind of he
was asked about it this isn't him
tweeting he's doing an interview about a
different project and the guy brings up
the mcu and he brings up fireballs he's
like yeah i heard about it i love to be
on it uh i think i should be in it and
he should be in it yeah and he's
basically like uh you know at some point
they call you and they give you the plan
you gotta go find a house to rent
he's just waiting he's just trying to do
his job look folks you casted him all
right he auditioned to be captain
america and you said not good enough you
kicked him to the curb and then you
called him up again when you needed a
fall guy when you needed a cap who would
chop someone's head off that's right
okay and he showed up he did the work
call him up you can't have a
thunderbolts without a captain america
port you've got to have a captain
america s character in your thunderbolts
you've already cast this guy just tell
him when he needs to run a house in
atlanta we like
on this show too great actor also his
wife super talented actress meredith
hagner great on search party
he's been asked about it
oh my god are they great
yeah
it might be uh yeah come on this show
and spit in a tube and then we'll do a
23andme after that hit the graphic again
feels like they're screaming in pain yes
they are ah
okay well how thirsty do we think why
russell was i hate to do this because i
was just forced to drink the first glass
of water i've ever drank in my life
i think this is a bit of a
i guess i am a little thirsty yeah black
i'll bless you dashiell
uh
yeah yeah i would say it doesn't feel
sahara it doesn't feel like he's being
asked about it he's not being outwardly
aggressive about it
um and we are all kind of assuming it is
going to happen yeah right it's not much
so yeah i'll go i'll go
a little parched yeah
i was going to say sahara i know
bless you bless you i know that he's
being
i know that he's being asked the
question but he didn't have to go the
extra mile and be like they never texted
me i gotta say i feel like that's a
classic deflection of he already knows
exactly what's gonna happen so he's
making a little bit i think he's playing
smoke that's nice but he came off like a
butthole to me so
okay so split the difference half a
glass okay well now you go with your two
years half a glass half a glass half a
glass half a glass half hour
oh that might be two thirds
i watched thirsty thespians when i was
15. it was a great movie uh i was on one
of those scrambled cable channels
um mine is for simulu
because i don't know what i'm talking
about
so
what pisses me off that people are
saying that he's thirsty is that like
wyatt russell he's already in all the
movies or he's already in a movie he has
a movie after i mean chi and then him
being like yeah i i just genuinely think
they didn't invite him to the marvel
panel at san diego comic con because he
doesn't have any
any movies that are coming out that are
about him
announced yet yeah yeah and the director
is working on um king dynasty yeah so i
don't think they were like oh we don't
really need to have him out here even
though he was at san diego comic-con and
so i think him just saying genuinely
like my years are going to be pretty
busy it's like yeah because if you're
you're if you're kate bishop for years
are going gonna be busy if you're a hot
guy you're here is gonna be busy
everyone's here's about to be busy
there's two films that are requiring all
of you guys to be there and it's uh it's
secret wars and i'm sure uh secret
invasion is gonna have a lot of them so
it's like yeah his years are gonna be
busy you guys he's not thirsty he's just
saying what his job is also he's fine as
hell and he wears jordan's like no man
well i'm on the show simon show off
those jordans see me on the break room
hashtag hashtag
in the break room we gotta start a
movement here to get him on we know he
watches new rock stars he watched me and
mt's videos jessica yeah
i'm telling you i'm voting sahara
whether no matter what you said the man
started the twitter campaign to play the
character that he plays
there is nothing thirstier than that he
could you could spend the rest of his
life never mentioning the character
again he's sahara thursday i thought we
were talking about we are
going forward yeah oh no i thought we
were choosing when they were thirsty
like how she was thursday in her tweet
it is mandatory funny i mean technically
he's on the mount rushmore i didn't know
he did that on twitter at all that's why
i used i was like no he's not thirsty
about san diego comic-con but i don't
run mandatory fund you guys again super
successful his thirst worked out great
for him you know we're not getting a lot
of yes ending on today's mandatory fund
and i would like to say that after this
people will be subjected to a mandatory
improv class but we learned some
agreements i just don't want to be made
an idiot you're not i am you did a great
job but the movie was thirsty that's
thirsty i think i agree full sahara full
sahara not chugging this but i will
drink it i don't think it's that thirsty
wow i think he's just
i don't what happened in the past is the
past okay okay he's one of the all-time
thirsts uh that has to be disputable
kill it if you have to
yeah
and then i'll i'll finish up here
yeah but but by the way guys zach could
sing this
for 85
85 bucks and zach sings this and i'm
saying celine dion uh you might you
might notice in the background of the
break room cast there are no mirrors yes
because the last time i sang on this
show yeah they all shattered this used
to be a hall of mirrors yeah
i will sing in the style of celine dion
i promise you that um my mine is gonna
be this this person was also in the news
um colin farrell did an interview
recently where he was asked about his
penguin character from the matt reeves
the batman series and we we already know
he's getting a spin-off series that kind
of much discussed uh hbo max series
there's going to be a spin off of the
batman uh at one point it was going to
be focused on gotham pd now it seems
like it's gonna be focused on the
penguin so he's getting that but within
the same interview he'd always said like
oh that's cool i'm excited about that
series i would i also want to be in the
next batman film
so it's not enough that this guy already
has a series focused on his character he
wants to make sure they don't make any
movies without him too
and to me that is
pretty thirsty so you're arguing for
your character i'm saying he's thirsty
this is rare we're supposed to be
defending the thirst no i'm not going
here's what i'm saying i'm saying it's
like he's extremely thirsty and i love
it okay mr ferrell do you i once um was
that in la fitness uh that colin farrell
was also working out in in a dirty wife
beater uh and like a baseball cap and
some like worn out track pants and i
loved it he could have been my white
trash uncle from rural colorado but
instead he was a talented actor colin
farrell great um uh the woke ones no
they're called a shirts i also them two
double okay those are double okay
symbols so i i i i [ __ ] on you well i
throw up white power symbols
i'm talking about i apologize
an a shirt um
a big but i'm a yes
fan i'm saying he's thirsty but i'm a
big fan of his thirst because also
the penguin character in that film was
one of my favorite parts oh yeah yeah
and i would i could watch him in every
movie
they've had so many batman movies and
they've had to come up with so many
titles just call the next one the
penguin mm-hmm
the batman is the background character
oh i love that character i'm sorry and i
will self-nominate myself as sahara yeah
are you you're watching
okay i i don't know that i can match
tommy's charging uh capability but i'll
do my best through your client i took
swift sips yeah she was doing swift
strips over here
i don't think we have time
to go over our next thing is this am i
getting is andrew getting pushed again
no we can't he's not gonna become our
matt damon we gotta we gotta talk about
it we only have five minutes is android
getting pushed in tomorrow god tell me
how did you charge yourself no you're
still going your little bird lips
[Applause]
super chatters thank you all uh today
heavy d
any truth to beta ray bill being one of
the background kids in thor love and
thunder that was supposed to get thor
powers in the end fight but didn't is he
gonna
chase chase-worthiness isn't better a
bill a horse
well there were multiple species of
little kid wait i'm sorry
was there a horse in the back no he has
a horse face but he's like a man body
horse face on a man body who's been
reading my fan face
my erotic fiction
it's all horsing around that's all
horrible a lot of folks to give it's
about a horse that plays a guitar
it's called nae nasty name okay
a lot of those little kids i didn't see
any of that
look like horses
but there were there were like a lot of
species there was like the werewolf kid
and they didn't explain it because like
the
most of the people settled in
newtonsburg or new asgard are as
guardians and there wasn't that many
there wasn't like a i know a horse boy
if i saw it in the first race so i
assume there's some part of that movie
that's cut out where gore is taking kids
from like multiple places uh
i don't know i don't know i was very
confused i don't know anything about
this rumor so we all thought he was a
kid licking salt in the back
he was a kid housing apples
he was the kid he was the kid that all
the other kids wrote right yeah
and there comes beta ray bill coming on
the track he's being followed by
thoroughness and owned by handle
starters
beta rate bill when's the asgard
i'm dying
man i'm telling you if there was a
little horse boy in that movie i would
have clocked it
you would have punched him oh [ __ ] him
the store virgil every 100 next time
should all do a dance-off
well the sing-off bombed okay yes
looking at the totals the sing-off was a
bomb it was great and if you guys want
to see a dance-off do you really want to
see zach do as a little shimmy
yeah those elbows are too high yeah
uh our apologies to eric voss and andor
we'll get to you tomorrow
yes uh eric boston put out a uh
breakdown of the new android trailer
that we've got that's up on the channel
one of these days this week we'll talk
about it here on the break room yeah uh
we'll get into that because we are very
excited it was a great trailer i think
it's moving in a much better direction
uh no shots of tattooing to be seen hey
how exciting tattoo uh but also a
reminder for all you breakers out there
uh you can submit your favorite clip of
the week from the break room on our
discord we've been airing uh our
favorite submitted clip of the week at
the end of the week so there's a bit of
the show that you liked uh maybe me
making a timely dick cabinet reference
uh and you know what
i'm not just kid i agree with you we
could be talking about andor but we're
talking about boys children instead and
you know what
i'm sorry that's on me we will talk
about android tomorrow i i promise come
back here on to the break room live from
our break room here at rockstar's
headquarters and also send in voicemails
on on that discord ask us anything uh
think of something ask a question maybe
you don't know how to make brownies
we'll share the recipe right here on the
break group submit that clip of the week
uh hit the like button if you've made it
this far into the show uh and tune in
tomorrow at the same time yeah we'll be
back every every day this week 3 p.m
pacific 6 p.m eastern that's right 11
p.m london yes talking about all that
the news of the day who knows what kind
of disaster will happen to warner
brothers in dc between now and
tomorrow's show we'll see what gets
greenland and when it gets put on the
shelf we'll see you tomorrow
show yourself dick cavett